la basse ardèche n'a plus à démontrer
ses possibilités touristiques
chaque année elle reçoit des vacanciers
de plus en plus nombreux
venus non seulement de la région rhône
alpes et de la france entière mais aussi
de l'étranger puisque le nombre de
touristes belges hollandais allemands
est sans cesse en augmentation
la principale activité de ces estivants
demeure sans doute la descente de
l'ardèche qui s'effectue par de nombreux
moyens le canoë la barque ou le bouddha
une descente qui jusqu'à présent joignez
l'utile à l'agréable
la pratique des sports nautiques dans un
cadre enchanteur
une phrase mise au passé car
actuellement l'ardèche est en passe
d'être victime de sa notoriété est à peu
près combien de personnes qui descendent
de l'ardèche par jour grosse forme et la
pose des problèmes certaines dans les
rapides
c'est la cohue les trois bateaux alors
c'est la castré les accidents les gorges
de l'ardèche ne sont pas encore victimes
de leur notoriété mais pourrait pourrait
un jour le le devenir parce que
finalement nous assistons à un
développement très rapide du canoë-kayak
de toutes les activités sportives dans
les gorges de l'ardèche
nous en sommes à un stade maintenant où
il est nécessaire pour nous de
d'organiser cette fréquentation
touristique
si nous voulons dans les années à venir
garder notre clientèle du point de vue
tourisme et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
nous avons un projet de réserve
naturelle dans les gorges de l'ardèche
visant finalement à protéger le site et
à organiser un petit peu la
fréquentation touristique au niveau de
la voie d'eau
alors que la préoccupation première des
services de sécurité et de prévenir
autant que possible les accidents on
assiste du côté des touristes et des
commerçants world embarcations à une
certaine inconscience
ainsi la mode pour les uns et la
rentabilité pour les autres
autorise-t-elle à relâchement au niveau
des contrôles de sécurité
il suffit pour pouvoir faire la descente
de l'ardèche d'affirmer savoir nager
sans que cela soit vérifiée une
situation qui autorise tous les abus moi
je suis un artisan c'est moi qui fais
mes bateaux je suis tout seul n'est pas
d'ouvriers
donc je prends mes responsabilités à
tous les niveaux or j'aimerais que mes
clients fassent pareil c'est à dire que
quand il loue un bateau eh bien il est
l'alliance gentillesse de me dire
véritablement s'ils savent faire du
bateau est très souvent malheureusement
s'aperçoit que c'est faux alors dans ce
dans ce contexte là si les gens ne
savent vraiment pas faire du bateau à la
limite je ne loue pas eh bien pourquoi
parce que je n'ai pas envie d'avoir le
problème de l'abandon dans les gorges
voire de la destruction complète du
bateau c'est malheureusement ce qui
arrive les gens vous disent nous savons
faire nous avons déjà fait
et quand on les met par exemple dans ce
petit rapide là ils sont absolument
incapables de le traverser
alors je suis amené quelques fois alors
refuser la location d'un bateau et
quelquefois je suis amené aussi si vous
voulez a accepté malencontreusement
quand je les vois arriver là bosch
obligés de courir après eux parce qu'ils
m'ont menti et ils partent quand même
vous voyez on perd le matin vers 9
heures et on emporte bien sûr son
matériel dans des sacs en plastique puis
on descend tranquillement aux visites
touristes bien sûr vous arrivez à ce
prêt vert qui leur soit vers 5 heures
sont squattés est ce que c'est une
descente qui vous paraît dangereuse
non absolument pas entre parce que bon
il ya quand même bien quelques rapides
mais au plus haut point bas est ce que
vous avez pris des cours vous même pour
faire du canoë kayak non chômeurs et
vous vous sentez quand même en sécurité
pour lui chaque fois que je vais leur
pose la question vous ne savez pas faire
du bateau on a l'impression de les
diminuer
je sais pas pourquoi parce que moi-même
personnellement j'ai appris très tôt et
à faire du bateau maintenant je m'en
porte très bien et au contraire je pense
que d'apprendre c'est quelque chose qui
est enrichissant je peux me tromper mais
enfin personnellement je trouve qu'on a
beaucoup plus de plaisir quand on sait
manipuler un bateau à contempler les
gorges de l'ardèche que quand on est
toute la journée crispé sur un bateau en
attendant l'accident le coût de la
descente de l'ardèche défendu moyens
utilisés les 33 km être parcourue en 4
heures parc est mû kayak pour un coût de
location de 60 francs embarque la
descente s'effectue à peu près en 5
heures et revient à 85 francs par
personne
enfin le voyage en boudin s'élève à 350
francs environ pour 20 personnes
nous avons
les gens qui viennent cheminots dont le
très grosse voiture vous voyez que vous
avez les gens qui viennent à pied
vous avez des jeunes qui viennent en
groupe il semblerait malgré tout que
nous ayons une majorité de gens qui sont
des classes sociales pas trop aisé oui
puisqu'ils n'ont quand même pas la
possibilité quelquefois d'avoir
d'acheter des bateaux ou alors ils
viennent de trop loin
1 et ceux qui ont de l'argent évidemment
peuvent s'acheter leur propre bateau je
pense que la majorité des gens qui
viennent sont des classes sociales peut
être un petit peu défavorisé au vaisseau
blanc argent alors on va commencer un
fort du tag et l'arôme l'arrière faire
la descente de l'ardèche par n'importe
quel moyen et parfois n'importe quel
prix c'est le phénomène qui se dessine
très nettement
or pour prévenir les accidents la
meilleure solution est encore
d'apprendre à manier les moyens de
locomotion qui nous d'être utilisé pour
cette descente dans ce domaine les cours
d'initiation canoë-kayak font de plus en
plus d'adeptes surtout au niveau des
jeunes comme on apprend à conduire une
voiture nous nous avons comme rôle
d'apprendre aux jeunes à conduire leurs
canaux tout ça pour ensuite se véhiculer
dans les gorges faire d'autres activités
et aussi déboucher sur les clubs nous
formons donc des jeunes aptes à ensuite
allés dans les clubs de c'est notre
vocation première est ce que cet
enseignement est un enseignement
définitif ou est ce qu'il demande à être
renouvelée
définitif rien n'est définitif c'est à
dire qu'on peut toujours progresser
mais les notions de base restent les
mêmes pour tout le monde d'ailleurs que
l'on soit le premier coup de pagaie d'un
champion ou d'un débutant est le même ce
n'est qu'après par le travail qu'on
arrive à un certain niveau technique
l'ardèche victime de son succès
touristique peut être mais la situation
n'est pas encore irréversible
les responsables touristiques et les
douze conseillers nature chargé de la
protection de l'environnement vassard
déj sont là qui veillent planifié
l'invasion estivale et éduquer le
touriste deux objectifs qu'ils se sont
fixés pour faire des gorges de l'ardèche
une véritable réserve naturelle ou dans
le cas de cette réserve naturelle nous
voudrions dire finalement aux gens qui
viennent en basse ardèche aidez nous à
conserver ce site de façon à ce que vous
puissiez le retrouver dans les années à
venir
c'est à dire éviter de jeter les ordures
n'importe où de sortir les ordures des
gorges de l'ardèche
quand on est capable d'amener 5 kg de
nourriture d'éviter de faire du feu dans
de mauvaises conditions
et il ya beaucoup de choses comme ça que
l'on va essayer de développer accordé un
gros effort d'information ce niveau là
la menace de pollution en ardèche n'est
pas une benne préoccupation quand on
sait que plusieurs tonnes d'ordures sont
ramassées chaque semaine le long des
gorges ce problème écologique s'il en
est est déjà prise en charge par les
ardéchois eux mêmes
plus que tout autre ils tiennent à ce
que leur région économiquement liée au
tourisme n'en devienne pas une victime